anna rook is in her late 20s and has a
severe anxiety disorder that impacts her
life in many ways the only person she
relies on is her elder brother conrad
who is dying of pancreatic cancer they
have no family besides each other which
is why conrad is always worried about
his sister moreover the siblings hide
deep secrets in different corners of the
house and are always wary of who they
let inside one night we see anna playing
with an old key alone in her room
suddenly she hears a strange noise
coming from the dark but it turns out to
be conrad sitting outside he calls her
to join him but anna rudely declines the
truth is that she hasn't left the house
in over 10 years because of her anxiety
disorder the next morning they are
joined by conrad's lawyer charlotte she
has been called to discuss conrad's will
and what anna will get after his death
but anna is not ready to have that
conversation yet then we are introduced
to dan a delivery guy who brings food
for the family every morning other than
conrad dan is the only person anna
enjoys talking to he is kind and has won
her heart over the course of time he has
been working for them as they chat they
hear a loud thud from conrad's room anna
rushes to her brother and puts him back
on the bed they spend the entire day
together talking about different things
conrad brings up the topic of their
father and asks anna to forgive him but
it only makes her angry a few hours
later anna is woken up by her care alarm
ringing she runs to conrad's room and
finds him
dead despite knowing that this was bound
to happen nothing in the world could
have prepared anna for her brother's
death after the paramedics take his body
away she cleans up the entire house and
gets rid of all of his medicine when
anna is at her lowest dan comes to her
aid and lends her a shoulder to cry on
he suggests she sell the house and move
somewhere else but anna is too connected
to the house to leave it as they chat
dan reveals that he wants to get out of
this town but isn't financially able to
do so anna abruptly leaves and returns a
few minutes later with a bag full of
money she wants him to take it and make
a better life for himself dan however
refuses to accept it even though anna
insists that she has more money than she
needs the next day is the day of the
funeral anna gets ready to leave but her
anxiety gets the best of her at the last
moment she desperately wants to say a
final goodbye to her brother but ends up
staying home drowning in her thoughts
suddenly a car stops outside and three
men approach her house they look through
the window to ensure no one is home
looking to rob the place anna panics but
before she thinks of calling someone one
of the guys named jp breaks the back
door and lets the other two in jp seems
to be the leader while his brother vance
and friend perry are his accomplices the
robbers are under the impression that
anna is at the funeral but the kettle
makes a noise and makes her presence
evident she quickly runs upstairs while
the guys start looking for her all
around the house perry finds her hiding
in the bathroom making her run
downstairs before he catches up to her
anna gets to the front door she can
easily run outside and save her life but
she freezes because of her anxiety jp
carefully closes the door and asks her
why she didn't escape she also had a
chance to call the police when she was
hiding upstairs but she didn't the truth
is it's because she's dumb the guys
think it is strange but all they care
about is the money she is hiding
somewhere in the house jp and his
brother vance continue looking for the
money while perry keeps an eye on anna
she tells him about her anxiety and how
she hasn't stepped out of the house for
over a decade perry is fascinated by her
and wants to check if she is telling the
truth for his own entertainment he
forcefully pulls her outside causing her
to pass out when jp picks her up to help
her anna wets herself vance is asked to
take her to her room and get her cleaned
as the other two search for the bag of
money they ultimately find a basement
with two doors without handles the doors
surely lead somewhere but are impossible
to open it is clear that either conrad
or anna wanted to keep these rooms a
secret meanwhile vance is trying to get
anna to change he is the weakest link
among the three and is not willing to
hurt someone for money anna also notices
this and tries to convince him to help
her she manages to convince him to some
extent but he eventually realizes what
she is doing in a fit of rage he
forcefully tries to make her change but
is stopped when the delivery guy dan
arrives he was at conrad's funeral and
has come to check up on anna because she
wasn't there anna is thankful that she
finally has someone to help her until
dan calls vance by his name revealing
that they are friends she realizes that
dan is also with the robbers and loses
her mind she runs downstairs and hides
somewhere away from the robbers jp and
perry get to dan and knock him out
revealing that he is in fact not a part
of their group after a few minutes of
searching for anna perry loses patience
and tries to kill anna's pet bird if she
doesn't show herself anna remains hidden
causing perry to hammer the poor bird to
death by now dan has woken up but jp
ties his hands and pushes him onto the
couch while the robbers are busy with
him anna runs to the bathroom but makes
noise while doing so vance is about to
catch her when anna stabs his neck
killing him on the spot the other two
are still with dan but the strange
silence makes them believe something is
wrong they ask vance to say something
only to hear the sound of anna dragging
his body to the basement soon they
locate the bloodstains on the floor and
follow them to find vance's dead body jp
holds his brother and cries promising to
avenge his death but no one cares the
mission turns into much more than just a
robbery for the surviving duo just then
perry notices anna behind a door but she
locks it before he gets in after that
she runs into a room and brings out the
key she was playing with at the
beginning of the film the key is then
used to open a console that consists of
a lever upon pulling it the stairs to
the basement retract trapping perry and
jp inside anna checks on them to make
sure that they cannot get outside some
time passes and the robbers try to break
the doors in the basement to get out but
it has been made to withstand any force
outside dan reveals that he is friends
with vance and had told him about the
money yesterday he feels awful for doing
so because he didn't know it would lead
robbers into her house anna still
refuses to untie his hands and asks him
about conrad's funeral he tells her how
it went and inquires about what conrad
would have done in a situation like this
anna thinks about it for a while before
breaking his finger and bringing him to
the basement door since the stairs are
missing he is standing at the edge of
the wall anna asks him to prove his
innocence by jumping into the basement
and when he refuses she pushes him
herself damn anna is hard dan cries in
pain holding his dislocated knee anna
then enters a hidden cabinet that shows
her live footage of the basement a while
later she comes to check up on them and
jp tortures dan in hopes that she will
feel sympathetic anna tells them to use
the first aid kit that is inside one of
the two locked rooms with no door
handles this time jp can open one of the
doors because anna has changed the
settings from upstairs however as soon
as he enters the room she presses a
button and he is locked inside jp finds
it extremely strange because the room
looks identical to the one he had seen
upstairs in the meantime perry tries to
break the second door and is successful
after many attempts he finds a freezer
and opens it to see dead bodies inside
shocked to the core perry runs outside
and comes face to face with anna now
that he has seen things he shouldn't
have she cannot let him live she hits
him with a hammer to his head the man is
about to strangle her to death before he
loses too much blood and dies outside
dan manages to move into the second room
and sees the dead bodies realizing that
something is very wrong at the same time
charlotte comes to check up on anna
because she hasn't been picking up her
calls anna pretends like everything is
fine and makes up an excuse for the
noise coming from the basement charlotte
doesn't think much of it and leaves
after making sure anna is okay after her
departure anna goes to the basement and
finds dan by the freezer she puts him
inside a cupboard which leads him into
the room where jp is locked the room has
a one-way mirror that she uses to keep
an eye on them jp figures this out and
tries to break it but anna informs him
that the glass is bulletproof she then
makes him wear a shirt out of a cupboard
it turns out that conrad and anna used
to drug men and lock them inside this
room then conrad joined the victims
through the cupboard and tortured them
while anna watched through the mirror jp
wants to know the reason they replicated
the room and whose shirt he is wearing
it is then revealed that anna's father
used to assault her even when she was a
child then one day conrad strangled
their father to death and became her
hero ever since then they have been
luring registered sexual predators into
the house and killing them anna believes
that they did the right thing because
offenders deserved the punishment but
according to jp both she and her brother
are psychopaths they got high from
killing their father and wanted to
relive the moment again and again anna
loses her mind at the accusations and
provides dan with a gun to kill jp she
wants him to pay for his deeds and
thinks she is helping him by doing so jp
pushes dan aside and gets a hold of the
gun he gets ready to kill dan but anna
stops him urging him to commit the
unthinkable she blames him for his
brother's death and declares that death
is the only way for his salvation
initially jp seems to be giving in to
her demands but he comes back to his
senses and points the gun at dan again
seconds before he is shot anna opens the
door and lets them out jp helps dan get
inside of the house but he isn't ready
to run away yet he looks at vance's dead
body filled with rage and a will to take
revenge dan tries to convince him to let
it all go but all he gets for it is a
punch in the face jp goes back in and
starts pouring gasoline around the house
anna brings him the bag full of money
hoping to send him away with it but he
refuses to take it and attacks her in an
ensuing struggle anna manages to run
upstairs but jp catches her and claims
that he has an idea he wants her to
relive the bad memories she shared with
her father by assaulting her the fact
that he is wearing her father's shirt
makes it even worse for anna just then
dan comes into the room and anna takes
advantage of the distraction to shoot jp
dead silence prevails as both dan and
anna look at the dead body realizing
that there is no one likeable in this
movie they go downstairs and dan leaves
without saying a word anna stays in the
living room for about an hour before she
finally decides to step out of the house
at last she has left her fear of
detachment behind and can exist outside
of the house without hyperventilating oh
goody now she can be a serial killer for
real in the final scene she lights the
house on fire and walks away subscribe
for more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching